640 klebebildchen stadien
nationalflaggen mannschaften fußballer
der portugiese raul camilo hatten über
wochen hat er die panini sticker der
fußball-weltmeisterschaft 2014 gekauft
und getauscht
savary
es ist einfach toll man muss das fühlen
ich lasse das album so lange leer bis
ich alles begann
aber wenn ich dann mit dem kleben
anfangen kann ich nicht mehr aufhören
durch das album voll ist ist die 80
seiten gefüllt sind ist für ihn der
rausch vorbei
don camillo lebt seit rund 20 jahren in
lissabon
er schreibt für ein fußball magazin mit
seinem vater im hotel fußball ist seine
leidenschaft
bm das heißt für ihn vor allem jagd nach
panini stickern
damit ist der in portugals hauptstadt
nicht allein überall wird verhandelt und
getauscht und viele wollen vor allem ihn
ergattern
portugals superstar cristiano ronaldo
die kioske sind mittlerweile zu
regelrechten tauschbörsen geworden
wir verkaufen das ganze jahr über die
panini klebebildchen zur wm
die gibt es nur alle vier jahre und dann
ist der andrang besonders groß
und noch etwas ist anders
panini sticker sammeln dann vor allem
erwachsene nicht nur junge leute modena
italien sitz von penny
hier werden millionen der weltberühmten
panini sticker produziert gegründet
wurde das unternehmen von den panini
brüdern 1961 im selben jahr erschien das
erste album seit der weltmeisterschaft
1970 in mexiko bringt panini alle vier
jahre wm sticker und hefte heraus
die bildchen gibt es heute mehr als 110
ländern
zwar wird immer wieder diskutiert ob
panini von jedem sticker die gleiche
anzahl produziert aber das tut der
sammelleidenschaft keinen abbruch
ramelow hat alle wm alt sie sind mehrere
tausend euro wert
ich sammle mit leidenschaft seit ich
denken kann
ich war fünf jahre alt als ich zu meiner
mutter sagte bitte komm mir alles dicker
die eu finden kannst
selbst gefüllt hatte das heft sowie e
mail agent ihn 1978 dieses hier zur wm
1974 in münchen hat er später gekauft
sammler bieten dafür heute zwischen 300
und 600 euro verkaufen will duo camillo
seine schätze aber nicht neben den
klassischen tauschbörsen gibt es online
plattformen und auch ein panini online
album as doch so kommen die digitalen
varianten ab muss das material spüren
die gesichter der personen sehen mit
denen nicht dicker tausche ich habe noch
nie online getäuscht ich weiß junge
leute machen das aber ich möchte die
anderen sammler kennen lernen
wenn es auch nur für zwei minuten
während einige ihrem geregelten alltag
nachgehen des don camillo ständig auf
achse
er will kein wm-spiel verpasst
und klebte eifrig fußballbilder sein als
vor dem viertelfinale will er damit
fertig sein
vier wochen turnier sind für ihn harte
arbeit das heißt viele spiele gucken
große leidenschaft genieße aber auch
nach den spielen die resultate ins
panini sticker album eintragen
obwohl die eigene mannschaft nicht mehr
dabei ist steigt auch in lissabon die
spannung wer wird weltmeister 2014 für
girokonto steht fest ein
südamerikanisches land
ich tippe bei brasilien 2014 auf
argentinien
der ballen brasilien rollt lissabon und
die ganze welt sieht man mit